now I'm going to show you a few
different ways to find this because
there there are sort of different cases
for it okay so just as an example let's
imagine there are seven people in your
group in your population or your Senate
sample or whatever it is and you want to
work out what are all the quartiles
in this set of data okay now be really
helpful if you have a couple of colors
the first thing you do is you find the
median right that's the easiest to find
and we're all really knowing how to find
it so it's a good starting point okay
can someone remind me how do I find the
median in an open set of scores I've got
two ways okay number one I can just sort
of climb from the bottom and from the
top and eventually I will be in the
middle okay does that make sense
what was my other way of doing it my
quicker way yeah very good
so I've conveniently named the scores
after how many there are
so n7 I'm going to add one chance today
hey and then I divide by two which gets
me to before okay so let's all label
this guy here right we already know
that's Q to the median now with your
other colors there I want you to notice
have a look at the rest of the data
you've got the same number scores below
the median as you do above the median
right so what you put up I want you to
read it it's like oh I've got a whole
new set of scores over here and this
little set of scores has its own median
does that make sense
do you have a look at these three and I
mean Costa very low three what's the
median in this little corner of the
world it's two right so this guy here
he's going to be the first quartile and
you rehearse it again for your upper set
of data and you are our six is in the
middle so that's your upper quartile so
this is the lower one and this is the
upper one
now to know whether you got it right or
not all you have to do is come back to
what quartile is just remember the
definition and see if it was successful
have a look have we divided up the
dialogue into four equal sections have
we done that yeah we have right look he
is the data below q1 he's the Dharma
between q1 q2 the one between q3 and q4
and here's what's above does that make
sense so this is not challenging but
this is nice and neat this is where
everything lands particularly neatly on
numbers so right another example for me
under movies let's just add a score also
before we start doing this we found the
quartiles but I haven't actually
calculated the interquartile range how
about what's the last step that's Missy
it's the easiest step actually yeah yeah
I just I just take the difference right
so maybe on the right hand side here you
won't actually calculate the
interquartile range is the upper
quartile take away the lower quartile
you don't have to keep on writing this
we can use the abbreviation upper take
away lower in this case you can see I've
circled them in black so it's 6 take
away 2 and that gives you the actual
interquartile range okay now by the way
can you notice right see how I've got um
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 I could have made this guy
over here this 7 I couldn't made it like
100 right making a huge outlier the
range will change but the inter quartile
range will stay the same so it's kind of
like trying to avoid this uh problem
here you like big deal the interquartile
range is cool all right all right let's
have a look again let's go through this
and try and work out each of the
individual pieces right firstly but when
we start which port on to be fine first
q2 because the middle ones always the
easiest to spot so you have a look again
can we do it the quick way that's like
try and practice it how many turns on it
8
so you add one which gets you to nine
nine divided by two is four and a half
so that means here's the fourth and
fifth terms right so I'm going to say I
used a red didn't I I'm going to say
right in here right for 45 that's the
median huge soon and then what did i do
from here to get to the rest of the yeah
I remember I imagined hey look I have
separated using the median the dot into
two different chunks and I'm going to
treat them one pump three times I'm
going to treat each of them as kind of
it's into its own population right okay
so what's the median down here okay so
they're between two and three so two
point five so that is q1 and I'm gonna
row has the same thing over yeah six
point five that's cube okay so you can
see sometimes the numbers all of your
quarters will land on some of the scores
just like the meeting sometimes it
doesn't it lands all between now we did
it for seven scores we did it for eight
scores I'd like you without me holding
your hand could you do it for nine
scores and for ten scores as well just
do that as example3 example4 I want you
to see if you can do it on your own
steam and then we'll share our results
in a minute
have a go okay consult me through let's
do the third one with nine scores
instead of seven point eight what are we
going to go to first where are we
looking we're going to go right to the
middle okay so cute is the easiest to
spot so I'm going turn I like that guy
okay now what's the thought process I go
through to find out what the other two
quantized
yeah good by the way can I just um
emphasize like you see how I underlie
these in black right
it's important that you work out what
are you finding the median old for
example how do you look at this one
there's obvious for this one how do you
look at this one it matters whether you
say this is where you're finding the
median or whether you include the five
or not okay
do you include the five or do you leave
it aside and just say well there are
four scores just think about that for a
second before I answer that question how
would you be able to tell whether you
include the file or not keep that keep
that thought in your head let's let's
find what they are under this scheme
what's the young what do you reckon q1
is this case and q3
okay cool okay now how am I going to
work out whether I did this right or not
apart from of course look at the back
we'll call relying on a teacher to tell
you yeah fantastic so I want to look at
each of these spots each of these
dividers and see were they successful in
making sure that there's equal arm equal
numbers between each of them
and it works doesn't it look you've got
two scores here are the two scores in
between two and three - s'mores between
I can see you get the idea right now can
you imagine don't don't write this
because it's going to be wrong imagine
if I did included the fire does that
mean if you'd included the fire like
this okay we already know okay this guy
is done so he's cute too if I included
the five which score is which which
trees which score is q1 which was k3
what's q1 on this on this scheme of
doing it it's gonna be the three right
and which one is q3
if I include the five again it's gonna
be the seven right but do you see the
problem do you see what's emerge right
look Oh again I'll do the count okay I
own to the left of q1 and how many
scores do I see I see wanted to
then I look between q1 and q2 and how
many scores do I see between the
quartiles there's only one swarm right
it's just the four do you see that right
and then again there's only one score
here and you've got two scores of it so
it's a symmetrical but they're not
quarters you haven't divided up into
four equal sections okay so that's how
you do it like I always like I struggle
to remember and I actually when I learnt
them I just learnt as a random rule that
you don't include you too because
because the texture it's home he not
saying clickety but this is the reason
why like you've got to make sure they
are actually quartiles and there's four
equal sections okay you wanna maybe skip
and just tell me which one's q1 q2 and
q3 are for this last set yeah three
that's nice and easy because you can see
there's an odd number of it and
fantastic okay so you can make hang of
it these four examples they're all the
ones you need to do because if you do
the next one how old do you see this a
pattern to use a pattern this first one
the court allows all land on scores
two four six yeah have a look at this
one when the quartiles land always in
between they're all they're all heart
have a look at this one you've got the
middle one on a score and then outside
of scores then here you've got in
between scores and all scores your next
one what's going to happen to which one
of these will it be if you've got eleven
scores all of them are going to land
you're going to be back in this
situation do you see ever one of the
ways you know is from seven stores to
eleven scores right you've added on four
scores right so it's just like slightly
and see how I've got one two three four
one in each quartile well you're just
gonna have one extra one so each one
that's it
okay so these for all the different
kinds of ways you've got quartiles just
draw them out there are four videos you
can work out like you know how we did n
plus 1 or 2 there's other ones which go
like in 2n plus 3 on 4 it gets a bit
confusing and people
the role so I think writing the scores
out isn't much simple okay how many
questions yes yes so we're going to look
at box and whisker plots we're going to
be drawing a lot of them tomorrow and I
have also forgotten to actually
calculate the interquartile range for
each one can you just quickly tell me
what's the ratio okay so there there's
four here five it's spaced out and here
also five okay good so the box and
whisker plot is going to take in a water
school so it'll put a line there it
takes each of these quartiles and put a
box around them and then it takes your
highest score like this and that's what
makes your whiskers but we're going to
spend a bit more time in that tomorrow
okay that's all it is to a bottom - oh
by the way like these these these things
here they also called these five numbers
they call the five number summary or
five-point summary of a set of scores so
you'll hear that phrase sometime
tomorrow okay